[Música]
26 de febrero de 1979 la Reina Isabel II
inaugura oficialmente el primer
rascacielos de Dubai se trata de la
Shake rachid Tower más tarde conocida
como el World Trade Center de Dubai
queridos amigos amigas en su momento fue
la torre más alta de todo Oriente medio
lo sorprendente que fue levantada en
medio del desierto en un lugar donde
como podéis ver no había gran cosa así
que la operación no parecía tener mucho
sentido sin embargo fue toda una
declaración de intenciones con 39
plantas y 184 metros de altura este
rascacielos dejaba claras las
intenciones del nuevo dubái que estaba
comenzando a nacer convertirse en un
centro clave para los negocios en
Oriente medio ese era el objetivo hoy 5
décadas después ese sueño se ha hecho
realidad
Dubai se ha convertido en uno de los
mayores ejemplos de transformación
desarrollo y éxito económico de toda la
historia y no No solo son palabras
actualmente en esta ciudad de emirato
encontramos el edificio más alto del
mundo el mayor centro comercial del
planeta algunos de los hoteles más
lujosos uno de los mayores aeropuertos
internacionales un megapuerto de escala
mundial y casi 400 rascacielos esto
quiere decir que desde que se inauguró
el World Trade Center de Dubai esta
ciudad ha construido cerca de 10
rascacielos nuevos cada año y eso no es
todo Dubai también es la ciudad del
mundo la número uno con más super
rascacielos esto es Torres de más de 300
metros de altura ninguna otra se acerca
y sobre todo se ha convertido en un
auténtico imán para atraer turistas
empresas y negocios de todas las partes
del mundo y amigos si la historia de
Dubai es resplandeciente la de Singapur
no se queda atrás
esta ciudad estado es una de las
metrópolis más ricas prósperas y
exitosas de todo el mundo en las últimas
seis décadas y pese a tener menos de 6
millones de habitantes ha pasado de ser
una pobre Plaza a convertirse en un
importante centro financiero industrial
y comercial gracias a ellos Singapur se
ha convertido en uno de los países más
ricos y desarrollados de todo el mundo
en términos de pib per cápita y
exceptuando a los microestados el fmi lo
sitúa como el cuarto país más rico de
todo el planeta hablamos de un pib per
cápita esperado para 2023 de más de
90.000 dólares y ojo porque esta ciudad
pese a su diminuto tamaño tiene incluso
una de las fuerzas armadas mejor dotadas
de todo el planeta por ejemplo Singapur
tiene más aviones de combate que las
fuerzas aéreas de países como Canadá
Suecia o Países Bajos de locos lo
miremos por donde lo miremos los números
de estas dos metrópolis son increíbles y
de hecho la red de investigación sobre
globalización y ciudades del mundo la
sitúa Ni más ni menos que como dos de
las nueve ciudades más influyentes y
económicamente significativas de todo el
mundo solo están un paso por detrás de
Nueva York y Londres las dos grandes
capitales mundiales fijaos
[Música]
y precisamente por eso aquí en
visualpolitik ya os hemos contado en
varios vídeos como Dubai y Singapur
consiguieron despegar y convertirse en
Auténticos cohetes económicos
comerciales y financieros básicamente
hablamos de dos ciudades que se
convirtieron en una especie de Ciudad
empresa De hecho no es casual que los
aeropuertos de estas dos ciudades se
sitúen entre los más transitados de todo
el mundo por ejemplo en 2019 el último
año previo a la pandemia el aeropuerto
de Dubai movió a 97,3 millones de
pasajeros y el de Singapur a 68,3
millones y de hecho en esta línea nos
faltó prestar más atención a uno de los
elementos claves de todo este proceso la
conversión de los gobiernos de estas dos
ciudades en Auténticos emprendedores y
la pregunta es hasta qué punto fue
importante el emprendimiento público en
el crecimiento y el desarrollo de estos
dos grandes polos económicos de qué
estamos hablando exactamente cuando
decimos que los gobiernos de estas
ciudades fueron Auténticos emprendedores
se puede exportar el modelo que tanto
éxito ha tenido en Dubai y Singapur a
otros lugares más pobres queridos amigos
amigas En este segundo vídeo de la serie
que estamos preparando en colaboración
con Harvard International review os
respondemos a todas estas preguntas os
dejamos más información en los links de
la descripción así que sin más preámbulo
arranquemos
[Música]
columnas en la arena del desierto al
mundo
[Música]
en 1997 Mohamed alabar ex director
general de desarrollo económico de Dubai
recibió un encargo fundar emar
properties hoy una de las marcas más
vistas y reconocidas de todo Dubai su
nombre está por todas partes no es
extraño es la promotora que ha llevado a
cabo los mayores proyectos de la ciudad
el desarrollo del Downtown del Burj
Khalifa del Dubai Mall de Dubai Marina o
de muchos de los hoteles de lujo
Hablamos de una empresa que ha
desarrollado la mayor parte de las obras
que han dado forma al actual Dubai
Prácticamente todo lo que es
característico en esta ciudad ha sido
promovido por emar Pero quién está
detrás de esta promotora Pues bien
descubramoslo muy buenas Alberto el
encargo de poner en marcha esta compañía
está promotora fue del propio gobierno
del emirato du Haití el mismo gobierno
que luego en el año 2000 la sacó a
cotizar en la bolsa local y que hoy
sigue controlando casi el 30% de una
empresa que con el paso de los años ha
convertido en toda una multinacional Oye
Martina en un montón de países
diferentes gracias a lo cual por ejemplo
en 2022 tuvo un beneficio neto de casi
7.000 millones de dólares Pero por
supuesto la Joya de la corona de esta
compañía sigue siendo Dubai una ciudad
donde los proyectos nunca se terminan de
hecho uno de sus últimos grandes
proyectos está siendo precisamente el
desarrollo de Dubai Chris un enorme y
nuevo Distrito que los próximos años se
convertirá Seguro seguro en una de las
grandes atracciones de esta ciudad Por
cierto la mayor parte de la
participación del gobierno se canaliza a
través de icb la investment Corporation
of Duty el músculo de inversiones del
gobierno de mar controlado tiene
inversiones En otras muchísimas
compañías gracias Enrique de hecho la
investment Corporation of Duty ha tenido
mucho que ver con el éxito de esta
ciudad
este brazo de inversión del gobierno
controla activos por valor de más de
300.000 millones de dólares posee o
tiene participaciones en muchas de las
principales empresas locales como el
banco emirates nbd el Dubai islamic Bank
las compañías aéreas emirates o flight y
la promotora e-mar de la que ya os hemos
hablado antes entre más de 60 empresas
participadas total o parcialmente Y de
dónde procede el dinero que invierten
Pues básicamente de emitir deuda
reinvertir los beneficios y los
superávits de las cuentas públicas pero
lo más importante es que a lo largo de
los años el gobierno de Dubai ha
utilizado esta sociedad para promover
negocios en la ciudad o cubrir aquellas
áreas y eran importantes para el
desarrollo general Pero eso sí lo hizo
siguiendo un estricta política de
Mercado las empresas participadas o
promovidas tenían y tienen que ser
competitivas no solo en dubái sino que
tienen que lograr ser capaces de
competir en el mercado internacional
esto generaría beneficios suficientes
como para que este vehículo pueda seguir
invirtiendo en nuevos proyectos un buen
ejemplo es el caso de emirates
Es evidente que en 1979 cuando se
inauguró el World Trade Center de Dubai
esta ciudad tenía un problema estaba
aislada del mundo Quién querría hacer un
largo viaje para llegar a un sitio tan
inhóspito sin embargo si quieres
convertirte en un centro financiero
turístico y comercial necesitas una cosa
comunicaciones Pues bien para
solucionarlo en marzo de 1985 el emirato
de Dubai creó emirates una aerolínea que
revolucionaría el transporte aéreo
intercontinental y que lograría hacer de
esta ciudad de emirato uno de los
enclaves mejor conectados de todo el
planeta no importa si quieres volar a
Tokio a Sydney o a Londres en Dubai
siempre tienes conexiones para lograrlo
a comienzos de 1985 el gobierno de Dubai
le dio al empresario británico moris
flanagan 10 millones de dólares y todas
las facilidades administrativas que
fueran posible su objetivo lanzar en
cinco meses una aerolínea que tenía que
funcionar bien y ganar dinero no habría
subsidios ni protección extra la empresa
tenía que volar nunca Mejor dicho por sí
misma y vaya si lo hizo
[Música]
hoy emirates es una de las aerolíneas
más grandes y rentables de todo el mundo
tiene actividad en 148 aeropuertos de
todo el mundo y en 2022 Pese a que el
sector todavía arrastra los efectos de
la pandemia ganó casi 3000 millones de
dólares pero sobre todo emirates
consiguió que Dubai sea uno de los
enclaves mejor conectados del mundo lo
que ha facilitado que lleguen hasta
ciudad trabajadores empresarios
inversores Y por supuesto también
turistas fijaos
7 de agosto de 2023 Dubai recibe más de
8,55 millones de visitantes en 6 meses
superando los niveles anteriores a la
pandemia El caso es que junto a las
zonas económicas especiales los bajos
impuestos y la seguridad jurídica el
éxito Dubai tiene otro ingrediente clave
lo que podríamos denominar como el
espíritu emprendedor de su gobierno pero
emprendedor no para crear ineficientes y
elefantes empresas públicas sino para
impulsar la creación de empresas que al
tiempo que promueve la economía local
tienen que ganar dinero y ser muy
competitivas me cueste Pero eso ni
siquiera es todo lo cierto Es que la
idea del Estado emprendedor va mucho más
allá en Dubai la inmensa mayor parte de
los proyectos públicos salen adelante
solo si tienen visos de ser rentables y
el gobierno también apoya a las empresas
privadas por ejemplo sin ir más lejos
una de sus últimas iniciativas ha sido
lanzar un fondo de casi 300 millones de
dólares para promover que 1000 empresas
tecnológicas nuevas se instalen en Dubai
en fin ya lo veis casi que podríamos
decir que este emirato Ciudad funciona
más como una empresa que como un
gobierno convencional y desde luego hoy
por hoy su éxito es innegable Claro que
no es un caso único el éxito de Singapur
tiene también mucho que ver con todo
esto atentos
[Música]
la ciudad del merlion
en 1942 Los japoneses se hicieron con el
control del enclave británico de
Singapur una ciudad estratégicamente
situada el Imperio británico había
convertido en una importante base naval
y que sufrió mucho durante la Segunda
Guerra Mundial al final de la misma la
ciudad era un desastre los daños
sufridos eran enormes muchas
infraestructuras sino la mayoría estaban
destruidas y las tasas de mortalidad
violencia y corrupción eran altísimas
Singapur Era una ciudad muy pobre en la
que prácticamente nadie en su sano
juicio querría vivir y sabéis que el
futuro no pintaba mucho mejor luego la
guerra de Corea y la demanda mundial de
estaño y caucho lograron que las cosas
mejoraran y Singapur recobrara su papel
como Puerto comercial pero poco más
incluso existía La amenaza de que la
ciudad sufriera una Revolución comunista
en 1958 la ciudad logró su total
autonomía y en 1963 tras declarar su
independencia
del imperio británico se integró en
Malasia sin embargo la cosa no funcionó
en el 65 la federación malaya echó a
Singapur comenzaría así su camino en
solitario lo cual no permitía ser
particularmente optimistas Singapur era
básicamente una isla pobre y sin
recursos naturales ni siquiera tenía
suficiente agua potable para dar de
beber a su población el agua tenía que
importarse de Malasia
por supuesto hoy las cosas son
totalmente diferentes Durante los
siguientes 60 años Singapur experimentó
un Boom sin precedentes que lo ha
llevado a convertirse en el cuarto país
más rico de todo el mundo un lugar
tremendamente próspero y con uno de los
niveles de vida más altos de todo el
planeta por supuesto como ya os hemos
contado en visualpolitik la apertura a
la inversión extranjera un alto nivel de
seguridad jurídica impuestos
relativamente bajos y una Clara vocación
por fueron elementos clave sin embargo
el éxito de Singapur también ha tenido
otro ingrediente al igual que hemos
visto con el caso de Dubai el gobierno
de Singapur también Tuvo una Clara
vocación emprendedora no es así Enrique
Sí en 1974 el gobierno de Singapur fundó
tema seca una especie de fondo soberano
o brazo de inversión que hoy gestiona
activos por valor de casi 300.000
millones de dólares americanos lo que
supone más de 50 mil dólares por
ciudadano por cabeza lo más curioso de
todas formas es que el gobierno de
Singapur creó este vehículo financiero
para aglutinar a las empresas públicas y
alejar de ellas a los políticos y a los
funcionarios La idea es que las 35
empresas pertenecientes o participadas
por el estado En aquel momento
funcionarán como auténticas empresas
privadas incluso Aunque seguirán
perteneciendo al estado ese fue el
comienzo pero luego con los beneficios
reinvertidos empezaron a invertir en
nuevas empresas para impulsar su
crecimiento hasta el año 2002 por
ejemplo temas se concentró la inmensa
mayor parte de sus inversiones En la
propia Singapur pero luego comenzaron a
invertir en el resto del mundo sobre
todo eso sí en Asia La idea es que esas
en empresas extranjeras crearán o
fortalecerán los lazos de estas empresas
con la propia Singapur por ejemplo casi
una cuarta parte de todas sus
inversiones hoy están en China al final
con el paso de los años temasec no solo
permitió profesionalizar las empresas
públicas sino que también se ha
convertido en una enorme hucha para el
gobierno y ha contribuido a impulsar un
montón de nuevas empresas sobre todo en
sectores considerados estratégicos para
la ciudad os acordáis de lo que antes
hablábamos de emirates pues es Singapur
ocurrió Algo similar temasek es el mayor
accionista de Singapur Airlines tiene el
55% de las acciones con su ayuda esta
aerolínea no solo conectó a Singapur con
el resto del mundo sino que también se
convirtió en una de las aerolíneas más
reputadas y lo que por supuesto es aún
mejor también en una de las más valiosas
y rentables compañías aéreas de todo el
planeta el beneficio estimado para 2023
se acerca a los 2.000 millones de
dólares americanos y lo mismo podríamos
decir de otras muchas compañías queridos
amigos con este tipo de estrategias
tanto Dubai como Singapur lograron
varios objetivos primero cubrieron
algunas carencias importantes como las
comunicaciones segundo contribuyeron a
profesionalizar las empresas públicas
una de las trágicas ilusiones que tienen
muchos países del Tercer mundo es la
noción de que los políticos y los
funcionarios públicos pueden desempeñar
con éxito funciones empresariales es
curioso que ante la abrumadora evidencia
de lo contrario la creencia persista
tercero ayudaron a impulsar y
desarrollar un montón de sectores
económicos lo que a su vez atrajo a un
montón de empresas y profesionales
extranjeros
y cuarto han creado una hucha enorme que
genera miles de millones de dólares de
beneficios cada año y no olvidéis que
estamos hablando de dos territorios
relativamente pequeños dubái tiene una
población Incluyendo a todos los
profesionales extranjeros de apenas unos
3 millones y medio de personas Singapur
por su parte unos 5 millones y medio y
pese a ello las cantidades que estamos
analizando son formidables por supuesto
además de crear estos brazos de
inversión ambos gobiernos abrieron sus
puertas de par en par a las empresas
extranjeras y promovieron la actividad
empresarial como si no hubiera mañana
entonces la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es se podría replicar este
mismo modelo para ayudar a desarrollar
regiones mucho más pobres Sería posible
crear ciudades parecidas en lugares de
África o incluso América Latina y ojo
que no es tontería por ejemplo la falta
de seguridad jurídica apertura y
conectividad hacen que Miami sea la sede
para las actividades en América de más
de 1.400 multinacionales si en
Latinoamérica encontráramos un espacio
tan amigable para los negocios como
Dubai o Singapur es muy posible que la
inmensa mayor parte de esas
multinacionales no estarían en Miami
sino en esa otra ciudad Por otra parte
mientras que Dubai y Singapur han
construido enormes huchas que además han
promovido el desarrollo económico los
países latinoamericanos exportadores de
materias primas no han tenido tanta
suerte por supuesto Venezuela es un
ejemplo de libro hablamos de decenas y
decenas de miles de millones de dólares
que en lugar de contribuir al desarrollo
nacional fueron dilapidados pero sea
como sea llegados hasta aquí la pregunta
ahora es para ti qué te parece el modelo
de gobierno emprendedor de Dubai y
Singapur crees que fórmulas así serían
replicables en América Latina o en
África déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios Esperamos que esta nueva
pieza entre visualpolitik y Harvard
International review o os haya resultado
tan Interesante como a nosotros es así
No olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte al Canal si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho muchas gracias por estar
ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]